[music]
[music] Hallelujah.
>> [music]
>> Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
Well, this lecture has a strange name.
It's titled A Stone to Rest Your Head.
And uh it's not a rock. It's a stone.
But uh Peter had a relationship with
Jesus.
And Peter
recognized that Jesus was the rock of
all ages. He was the ultimate stone on
this planet.
And so we need to recognize that we need
to have a relationship with Jesus
Christ.
Now
this lecture starts with an interesting
prophecy and we've dealt with this
prophecy to some extent although of
course we didn't deal with the book of
Daniel we actually dealt with the book
of revelation but since the book of
revelation is steeped in the book of
Daniel and takes its symbolism from the
book of Daniel we have to jump back and
forth somewhat
there's this amazing prophecy in the
book of Daniel that we've touched on
before the prophecy of the 2003 300
days. Unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. Daniel 8:14. Now, the full
extent of this prophecy is one that is
incredibly important in the world. And
as you all know that the 70 weeks
portion of that property of that
prophecy has actually been cursed by uh
rabbitical societies because it points
to the Messiah to Jesus Christ as the
only one. Actually the prophecy starts
from the going forth of the decree to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem.
And that decree went out when Artexus
made that decree in 457 BC.
And then it gives the exact time periods
of the restoration of Israel. And it
gives the exact time period as to when
the Messiah, the prince would come and
also the week of his sacrificial death.
All of those are included in this
fantastic prophecy. And as a portion of
the prophecy cut off for the Jews, but
the prophecy continues for 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. Now, if you take 2,300
day years, then you get to a date 1844
with which we cannot do much unless we
understand some of the principles
involved. But there's a whole lecture
coming which is called 1844 and the
final onslaught. We'll be dealing with
more of those issues in that lecture.
So the cleansing of the sanctuary, what
did this entail and what has this got to
do with this study that we're dealing
with tonight? Well, Daniel 8:1 17 tells
us a little bit of about this. So he
came near where I stood. And when he
came, I was afraid and fell upon my
face. And he said unto me, "Understand,
oh son of man, for at the time of the
end shall be the vision." So this vision
that Daniel got didn't concern his time.
This is the 2,300
evening morning portion of the prophecy.
Didn't concern his time. It concerned
the time of the end, not the end of
time. the time of the end. So when does
this time of the end start? And what
does this prophecy tell us? Daniel 8
verse 26. And the vision of the evening
and mornings, that's the 2,300 day
prophecy, which was told is true.
Wherefore shut thou up the vision, for
it shall be for many days. So this
vision of the 2,300 evening mornings is
shut up. It is a sealed vision. It is a
closed vision not to be understood until
the time of the end. For at the time of
the end shall be the vision.
So the decree to rebuild Jerusalem as I
said went out in 457 BC. There were
actually three decrees, but only one
decree
meant complete political freedom as well
as the reconstruction of Jerusalem. All
the other decrees had only been there
for the temple. So this is the only one
that we could take. And he said unto me,
unto 2,300 days, then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed. Now what is the
sanctuary that shall be cleansed? Daniel
8:14,
the 2,300year prophecy, there was a time
period which was called the 70week
prophecy. 70 * 7 days, 490 days, 490
years. If we start with 457 BC, that
ends in 34 AD and it's divided up in two
weeks. It's a fantastic prophecy. And it
tells us that in the middle of the last
week he messiah shall put an end to
sacrifice and offering. The sacrificial
system will come to an end. And the
sacrificial system of course was a type
of his own sacrifice. So when Jesus dies
that sacrifice that sacrificial system
comes to an end. It is no longer ne
necessary. It just served as a type for
what was going to come.
Well, 34 A. What happened in 34 A? In 34
A,
Steven was stoned and the gospel went to
the Gentiles. In fact, Jesus had said to
the disciples, "Go ye first to the lost
children of Israel." So, even after the
crucifixion,
there was work done amongst the Jews.
But then in 34 AD,
Paul was called and he was to be the
apostle to the Gentiles. Peter had a
vision at that time where he was taken
to Cornelius who was a non-Jew and he
was very reluctant to go. But God gave
him a vision of unclean animals and a
sheep coming down. And Peter interprets
this vision in front of Cornelius in
Acts chapter 10 and says to him, "God
has shown me that a I may not call any
man unclean."
So the gospel now went to the Gentiles.
But this vision continues
and it ends if you add it all together
in 1844. Now the proof of the pudding is
in the eating. And the fact that the
first part of the prophecy is fulfilled
to the letter tells us that this last
part of the prophecy must be more than
interesting to us. But Daniel didn't
understand the vision and he was told
that it was sealed unto the time of the
end.
Now the cleansing of the sanctuary, the
earthly sanctuary took place at the end
of the Jewish year. It was a day of
judgment symbolizing the final judgment.
Today they call it Yonipur and Yonipur
symbolized this cleansing. Now we'll be
dealing with this in greater detail. The
high priest went into the most holy. The
high priest then when he came out of the
most holy made atonement for the entire
sanctuary cleansing it of the recorded
iniquities. That means all sin that was
recorded was in type removed from the
sanctuary. So in other words even the
record of sin was removed. That means
that redeemed, the redeemed will stand
before God one day as though they had
never sinned. There will not even be a
record of their sin. So complete is the
redemption in Christ.
So since 1844, if this is a cleansing of
the sanctuary in an antiypical sense, we
have been living in what the Bible calls
God's judgment hour. And since 1844,
there have been some thunderous events
on this planet which really need to be
talked about. Now when was this vision
to be unsealed? Daniel 12:1.
And at that time shall Michael stand up.
Now we've already seen this in the
lecture yesterday. The great prince
which stands for the children of thy
people. And there shall be a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation. So right at the end of
time there will come a very troubles
shall be delivered everyone that shall
be found written in the book. So
sometime after this event,
this planet as we know it will come to
an end and something will take its
place. There will be deliverance. Daniel
12:4, "But thou, oh Daniel, shut up the
words and seal the book, even to the
time of the end. Many shall run to and
fro, and knowledge shall be increased."
Obviously the main knowledge here is
knowledge about the word of God shall
increase here in the time of the end to
make all these things understandable
in a another sense knowledge also of
course increased in a literal sense
Daniel 12 7 and 9 it shall be for a time
times and half a time now that you
should recognize by now from the many
times that we've dealt with it.
And when he shall have accomplished to
scatter the power of the holy people,
all these things will be finished. Okay,
fascinating. What does this tell us?
Well, the whole of Daniel, the chapter
deals with the battle between good and
evil. And here was to be this antichrist
system. In Daniel chapter 7, we have all
the details of that that arises. and for
1,260
years or 1,260
prophetic days or 42 prophetic months or
three and a half prophetic years, this
system will scatter the saints. This is
a reference to the period where the
Roman system
controlled the religious sphere on this
planet and persecuted God's people and
scattered them. So for a time, times and
half a time when he man of sin shall
have accomplished to scatter the power
of the holy people which is exactly what
he did. All these things will be
finished. So when is this time of the
end? When does it arise? sometime after
because this power did this from 538 AD
to 1798
when Bertierre sealed off the system and
called it quits and said this system has
now come to an end. The papal power was
restricted
and he said go thy way Daniel for the
words are closed up and sealed till the
time of the end. So the time of the end
starts after 1798.
Now when we did the book of revelation,
we actually came up to this fantastic
chapter, chapter 11, where something
arises out of the bottomless pit. Can
you remember what that was? A beast
arises out of the bottomless pit. The
same time period is mentioned in
Revelation 11 as the time when the
kingdom of darkness will start to be
manifested here on this planet. So at
this critical time after 1798
when the beast arises out of the
bottomless pit and the first thing it
does it makes war against the two
olive branches. Do you remember that the
word of God and we had two whole
lectures on how the word of God was
attacked and how it has been manipulated
by this very power.
Now, do you think God would leave the
world untouched to allow this kingdom of
darkness to spread its numerous errors
without a counter? Do you think it would
just be able to do that? Because this
kingdom of darkness is going to
encompass the entire world. This kingdom
of go darkness is going to control the
entire world. The Bible says that all
the world wonders after the beast.
Everybody bows down to him. In
Revelation chapter 17, the woman rides
the beast. And she has on her forehead
mystery, Babylon, that great prostitute
who makes all the people drink of the
wroth of this wine of her fornication.
So go your way, Daniel. The words are
closed and sealed till the time of the
end. Obviously the time of the end
begins after the time times and half a
time. So sometime around 1798
something must happen to counteract this
system.
Matthew 24:21 and 22. For then shall be
great tribulation such as not was since
the beginning of the world to this time
nor ever shall be. And except those days
should be shortened there should no
flesh be saved. But for the elect's sake
those days shall be shortened.
This is actually a reference here in
Matthew 24 to that 1,260day
period, which was to be this terrible
tribulation period, which will be
followed later by a time of great
trouble, which is the worst that will
ever have been on this planet. But this
time period is very prominent. This
1,260day
period is repeated seven times in the
book of Revelation as a period of great
nightmare. But God shortened the time
of darkness. How did he do it? Do you
remember what he did to shorten the time
of darkness? He brought about the
reformation.
So instead of this darkness having total
control for 1,260
years, the reformation cut the time
short and spread light. But this system
was determined to conquer the
reformation. And we saw how it went all
out to do that. If God had not done
that, if he had not brought about the
reformation, then everything would have
been over already. Nobody would be saved
because then all light on this planet
would have been extinguished. But for
the elect's sake, those days shall be
shortened.
We eh Leki, history and rise of
Russianism in Europe says the church of
Rome has shed more innocent blood than
any other institution that ever existed.
It is impossible to form a complete
conception of the multitude of her
victims. This is just a sad fact and it
would have wiped out all vestigages of
truth if God had not done something.
These are the great monuments of the
reformers. Many of them died at the
stake. But they were determined to speak
the word of God and to make the word of
God available to all people.
Then Mark 13 24 says after those days or
in those days after that tribulation
this period that is mentioned seven
times in the Bible
in this period after that tribulation
the sun shall be darkened and the moon
shall not give her light. There will be
celestial signs. Mark 13:4.
Now, who would those celestial signs be
for?
For those who do not know the Bible or
for those who do know the Bible.
Obviously, for those who do know the
Bible. But they had been scattered. They
had been scattered. The Bible says in
Daniel when he this antichrist system
will have succeeded to scatter the power
of the holy people. Where did they
scatter to? Where did the reformation
scatter to? Where was it?
It was in the new world. It had escaped.
And the bulk of it, the bastion of of
the Protestant world had come to this
continent that I'm standing on right
now. It had come to North America.
That's where the bulk were. There were
patches in southern Africa. There were
patches in the New World, Australia, and
New Zealand. But the bulk of it, the
power was here. So wouldn't they be the
ones to be able to interpret these signs
the best? Mark 13:4,
Revelation 6:12 and 13 says exactly the
same thing. And I and beheld when he had
opened the sixth seal. Now remember, we
went through the seals and each one of
the seals represents a time period in
history. And the opening of the seventh
seal is the coming of Christ every time.
The final one, the seventh one is the
culmination of all things, the coming of
Christ. So here when he opened the sixth
seal,
lo, there was a great earthquake.
We have an earthquake. The sun became
black as sackcloth. There was a
darkening of the sun. The moon became as
blood. The stars of heaven fell unto the
earth, even as a fig tree cast her
untimely figs when she is shaken of a
mighty wind. Revelation 6:12 and 13.
Exactly the same that Jesus had said
would happen after the tribulation of
those days, the sun will be darkened.
But was there such a day round about
this period, round about the end of the
1,260
days? Yes. There was a great earthquake,
one of the strangest earthquakes of all
time, the great Lissipon earthquake. In
fact, that was an earthquake that was
felt into the southern hemisphere. A
very strange earthquake. And then the
dark day of New England, so familiar to
old and young, came May 19, 1780, near
11:00, it began to grow dark, as if
night were coming. Men ceased their
work. The loing cattle came to the
barns. The bleeding sheep huddled by the
fences. The wild birds screamed and flew
to their nests. The fowls went to their
roost at night. It was so inky dark that
a person could not see his hand when
held up, nor even a white sheet of
paper. History of where New Hampshire
1735 to 1888, Boston Public Library.
That's a fact.
The Independent Chronicle said during
the whole time a sickly melancholy gloom
overcast the face of nature. Nor was the
darkness of the night less uncommon and
terrifying than that of the day.
Notwithstanding, there was almost a full
moon. No object was discernible,
but the help of some artificial light
which when seen from the neighboring
houses and other places at a distance
appeared through a kind of Egyptian
darkness which seemed impervious to the
rays. This was a very strange
phenomenon. These are historic facts.
These are not Christians writing. That's
a newspaper.
Great memorable events. The Connecticut
legislature was in session at the time.
So great was the darkness that members
became terrified and thought the day of
judgment had come. A motion was
consequently made to adjourn.
And then Hershel the great astronomer
frankly admits the dark day May 1978 is
one of those wonderful phenomena of
nature which will always be read with
interest but which philosophy science is
at a loss to explain.
There was no eclipse. There was no
reason why there should have been such
an event. But it happened. And that
night, the moon was blood red but didn't
give off any light. You could see it. It
was a full moon, but there was no light.
It was as if the sun had been darkened
and the moon could not reflect its
light.
And then the stars of heaven fell to
earth. November 13, 1833. So in the
right sequence, there was an earthquake.
Then there was a darkening of the sun.
The moon became his blood. And now there
was this strange event of this massive
meteor shower. November 13, 1833.
200,000 meteors an hour. There were so
many meteors you could read at night
with the light of the meteors. But the
interesting fact is that it didn't
really happen like it looks over here.
The meteors see seem to come from a
central point and spread over the sky
where whereas normally meteors just fall
haphazardly. So there were marvelous
celestial signs which were seen by
bibleelving
students on this continent.
And at that time a man by the name of
William Miller started preaching an
interesting message. William Miller 1782
to 1849.
Now remember that this prophecy would be
unsealed
at the time of the end after the
1,260day
prophecy comes to an end, the three and
a half years.
And he claimed unto 2,300 days then
shall the sanctuary be cleansed. and he
started working out this prophecy of the
2,300 years which had not been done
before. Nobody had ever done that. And
here suddenly comes a man and he does
this. And in the book of Daniel, it says
this will be understood in the time of
the end. And he worked out well this
prophecy comes to 1844. Then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed. What does that
mean? and he racked his brain and he
didn't know what it meant. And so he
figured, well, maybe the earth will be
cleansed. Then how would that be
interpreted?
When will the earth be cleansed? When
Christ comes again. So he says, well
maybe in 1844
Christ will come again. But of course
there's another verse which says nobody
knows the day or the hour. But having
studied this and found that the first
part of the prophecy relevant to Christ
is an absolute fulfillment
that even peaked the Jewish knowledge
and made them give a curse or
a decree against the study of that
portion of scripture. Well then maybe
the rest of the prophecy was somehow
very relevant and he started preaching
on this issue.
Now if he had understood the sanctuary
part of it, well then he would might
have related it to the earthly sanctuary
which serves as a type in the Bible for
the heavenly sanctuary. And so he might
have then come to the conclusion that in
there is a shift in emphasis to a time
of judgment. In other words, the evil
side gets its time to set up a kingdom.
And this is a the final judgment period
almost like an anti-ypical yonipur. And
then at the same time there will be a
counter message. So in the 1840s a group
of people that called themselves advent
believers. That means they believed that
the coming of Christ was imminent
and that he would come in 1844 sometime
then. And when he didn't come, they were
deeply disappointed. Now, who were these
Advent believers?
They were Christians from every single
denomination of Christianom existing at
that time. In fact, they incorporated
some 200 ministers of religion with
large parts of their congregations who
were waiting for this coming of Christ.
and they were actually mocked. But they
based their decision
on a study by Miller which sounded very
solid biblically and prophetically. Of
course, Christ didn't come and there was
a great disappointment and this movement
sort of dissipated except for a call
which continued to study the Bible. Now,
if God has a church, how can we find it?
What do people say? Well, there are over
300 different denominations in North
America, they said at this stage. Today,
there are literally thousands. Newsweek
magazine of 1994
calls the explosion of interest in
religion a search for the sacred. So, in
our time, there has been a major search
for truth. According to Time magazine,
the religious section, new religious
groups are exploding.
And uh by the 1990s there were 1,187
faiths and now today well over 2,000.
How do you know who's got the truth?
Well, here's a book called Religious
Controversy
in a friendly correspondence between a
religious society of Protestants and a
Roman Catholic Divine. This is a book
written by the Reverend John Milner
and he asks an interesting question.
And what is that question that he asks?
Here it is in his book. There is but one
question which is the true church. If
you answer that one question, you solve
every question of religious controversy.
And that's a very difficult task. And uh
if you have over 2,000 denominations to
choose from, well, maybe it's a task
that you might as well not even want to
venture into and say, "Well, let's just
give up. I mean, this is pathetic. Which
one is right?" Now, if you really think
about it, should it be that difficult?
What should be the standard
for Christianity to determine whether
somebody is telling the truth in all
aspects, yes or no? What should be the
standard?
>> The Bible. Okay. So, the Bible is the
standard. So, now let's take the Bible
as a standard and we go to
denomination X and we ask a couple of
questions. What do you teach regarding
whatever it is? Let's say baptism.
What do you teach regarding baptism?
Well, if you come to one denomination,
they will say we believe in infant
baptism. Are there denominations like
that today? Yes. And some of them will
say, "We believe in baptism by immersing
the infant." There are some groups that
do that. Others will say, "We believe in
baptism by infusion, pouring the water
over the head." Others will say, "We
believe in baptism by sprinkling."
And others will say Baptist for example
we believe in baptism by immersion of
adults. Some denominations say immersion
once.
Other denominations say immersion three
times in the name of the father, the son
and the holy spirit. And some of these
variations cons exist in the same
sisterhood of churches. For example, in
some Calvinistic sisterhood of churches,
you have infant baptism and you have
adult baptism in the same sisterhood.
It's very strange.
So which one is right? Are they all
right? Or is it okay? Does it make a
difference? What do you do?
Well, shouldn't it be a simple matter to
go to the Bible and see, well, how was
it done in the Bible? And then follow
the Bible by the letter, yes or no?
>> Okay. Well, let's take um communion, how
communion was held, what is to be done
at communion, what does this one do,
what does that one do, what does this
one do, etc., etc. And have a look what
does the Bible teach? And it shouldn't
be too difficult to determine, well,
that's what the biblical way is. What is
the doctrine on let's say the
antichrist?
Well, the old reformers, they were all
one on this issue. They pointed to Rome.
Every single one of them. Luther said
so, Calvin said so. Knox said so,
Swingley said so, Hus said so. They all
said that. Today they don't. Today they
have different doctrines. The one says
we believe in futurism.
that is that the antichrist will come in
the future sometime in the distant
future when the church has already been
raptured. Is there are there
denominations like that? Certainly are.
Great bulk of them say that. Some of
them will say no no no. The antichrist
was in the past. He existed in the time
of Greece and he was a Greek king by the
name of Antiochus Epipanus 4.
Now Daniel says he comes out of the
fourth kingdom. So he couldn't have come
out of the third kingdom. So here is a
confusion. So now it gets even more
confusing. Sometimes the same
denomination
teaches both. The same denomination
teaches both. That's really confusing.
Now the training of the ministers
for example teaches that preterism is
the way it was. He came out of the p in
the past in the time of Greece. But the
denomination is taught futurism. He
comes in the future. Now why is that?
Because the bulk of the opinion owing to
the other movements is swinging towards
futurism
because that's more interesting. You
see, then something is still bound to
happen. Preterism is boring because then
it's already happened. Do you understand
the point? So they teach both. How can
you teach both? That he came in the
past, but he's coming in the future.
Does that make any sense?
And so we have all these doctrines.
Shouldn't it be a simple matter to go to
the Bible and say, "Well, what does the
Bible say?" and then stick to the Bible
and eventually
somebody will have to give up a pet
doctrine somewhere along the line and
come back into line with the Bible. Yes
or no? Okay.
So, which one is the true church? Well,
my opinion would be the one that sticks
to the Bible 100%.
The book of Revelation actually reveals
the characteristics of this remnant. And
you remember yesterday we talked about
this woman in white. I have likened the
daughter of Zion to a comely and
delicate woman. Jeremiah 6:2. Say unto
Zion, "Thou art my people." Isaiah
51:16. So the church of God is related
to this delicate woman. I am jealous
over you with a godly jealousy. I've
espoused you to one husband that I may
present you as a chasteed virgin virgin
to Christ. 1 Corinthians 11:2, the
woman, the church.
Remember in Revelation 12:6, the woman
fled into the wilderness where she had a
place prepared to God that she should
feed her there a,23
score days. That is the 1,260
year period where Rome was persecuting
and scattering the people of God. And
most of them came to this continent and
here found solace in the dry areas. Not
many nations and peoples and tongues to
persecute her. And after that period,
what was to happen? We discussed it last
night. Verse 13. And when the dragon saw
that he was cast onto earth, he
persecuted the woman. The woman were
given two wings fly into the wilderness
place nourished for a time times and
half a time from the face of the
serpent. And then what date have we got
there?
1798 after the time times and half a
time. And then the serpent casts out of
his mouth water. What's that? Nations
again. Nations.
as a flood after the woman that he might
cause her to be carried away of the
flood. Earth helped the woman. The earth
opened her mouth, swallowed up the flood
which the dragon cast out of the mouth.
And the dragon was wroth with a woman
and he went to make war with a remnant
of her seed. Here's the first attribute
which keep the commandments of God.
Second attribute, have the testimony of
Jesus. So after the 1,260 days, the
dragon goes to make war with a remnant
that keeps the commandments and holds to
the testimony.
So what is a remnant? Obviously a
remnant is something that remains. It
looks like the original. So if the
original was a Bible believing group
believing in salvation in Christ and
Christ alone, then the remnant must have
that same appeal except that it also has
this sharp attribute that it keeps the
commandments which some of the previous
ones also did. The Valdenzas kept all
the commandments and were persecuted for
example on the Sabbath issue. So God's
church would arise sometime after 1798
in a land of political and religious
freedom. Here is the patience of the
saints. Revelation 14:12. Here are they
that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus. Notice it doesn't
say faith in Jesus. It says faith of
Jesus which is much more than faith in
Jesus. It means having the same trust
and reliance in Jesus as Jesus had in
his father. That's what it means. It
means a very strong relationship
with Jesus Christ.
Blessed are they that do his
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life and may enter
in through the gates into the city.
Revelation 22:14. This implies that the
commandments are going to become a test
in the last days and that it will make a
distinction between those who follow God
and those who don't. It doesn't
necessarily mean that you will be saved
because you keep the commandments. It
simply means that there will be this
distinction. So blessed are those that
do his commandments. not just say, but
actually do his commandments that they
may have the right to enter in. If you
love me, keep my commandments. John
14:15.
You know, John chapter 14 is a fantastic
chapter. It starts off with, "Let not
your hearts be troubled." Doesn't it do
that? It says, "In my father's house are
many mansions. I go to prepare a place
for you.
And then it says, I will come again to
take you to be where I am also. That's
the blessed hope, the coming and the
return of Jesus Christ. And then in the
same chapter, it says, if you love me,
then keep my commandments. Those are the
two attributes
which are central to faith in Christ.
Obedience to him shows that you
acknowledge him as your king.
And the fact that he's coming again must
be your hope, the blessed hope, Paul
calls it. So obedience and waiting for
the coming of Christ.
So the two distinguishing
characteristics of God's remnant church
are keeps the commandments of God. Does
that make any sense? Is that correct? Is
that biblical?
Number two, it has the testimony of
Jesus. We don't know what that is yet,
but it has it, right? Whatever that is,
it has that.
So, question, what is the testimony of
Jesus? Well, let's ask the Bible. Now,
John is in vision and an angel comes to
him and informs him and he falls at the
feet of this angel to worship him. And
this angel says to him, "See that thou
do it not.
I am thy fellow servant and of thy
brethren that have the testimony of
Jesus. So you cannot worship an angel.
So here we have have the testimony of
Jesus. Worship God for the testimony of
Jesus is the spirit of prophecy. There
you have the definition. Okay. The
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy. What does that mean?
Well, it's such a big concept that we'll
deal with it in a whole lecture.
We'll do it tonight.
Revelation 19 verse 10. So that's an
attribute we'll have to discuss in some
detail. So God's last day church would
keep the commandments and have the gift
of prophecy.
When Jesus ascended to heaven to
stabilize his church, the Bible says he
gave some apostles, some prophets, some
evangelists, some pastors, teachers.
Ephesians 4:11.
If this was what the church needed in
the beginning of its ministry, surely it
will need it at the end of its ministry
as well. Doesn't that make sense?
Even as the testimony of Christ was
confirmed in you so that you come behind
in no gift waiting for the coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ. 1 Corinthians 1:67.
All the gifts must be there.
So the Bible predicts the gift of
prophecy will be restored to God's
church in the last days. Surely the Lord
God will do nothing but he revealth his
secret unto his servants the prophets.
Amos 3:7.
So what must be restored at the end of
time? The fullness of the gospel. Surely
there must be someone who will take the
whole Bible and say our life must be
dictated to by what it says in the word
of God and not anything else. So if
Wcliffe discovered the authority of the
Bible
and Hus discovered obedience to God and
Luther discovered salvation by grace and
Kelvin discovered freedom of conscience
and Williams discovered baptism by
immersion all of which are biblical and
Wesley discovered lordship of Christ.
Then Miller discovered again the hope of
the second coming which is the hope of
the church. And Miller also discovered
prophecy as an important guideline. Can
prophecy save me? Yes or no? No. I can
know everything about prophecy and it
won't do one thing to save me. But what
can prophecy do? can tell me where I am
in the stream of time. And prophecy can
show me that the Bible is trustworthy.
If you take the prophecies in the Bible,
the prophecy of Ty for example,
fulfilled to the letter, to the letter,
including sweeping it off the face of
the earth and dumping the whole city
into the sea, including its dust. That's
a tough prophecy to fulfill. Make no
mistake. Somebody said to you today,
Vancouver will be swept off the land,
dumped into the sea, and even the dust
will be used and thrown into the ocean.
You would say, well, this man is
slightly mashugar, right? He has lost
it. But that prophecy was fulfilled to
the letter. All prophecy will be
fulfilled to the letter. And then there
must be a final restoration under the
guidance of the spirit of prophecy,
which encompasses all truth. Isn't
wouldn't that be logical? That would be
a logical thing.
But what if
this organization or this truth comes
into contact with all the others that
will not move further than their
founders and then unfortunately have a
clash with all of them. All of them.
Now, Revelation chapter 10 is this
marvelous chapter
culminating here within this sixth
trumpet where you have this one power
meeting the power that comes out of the
bottomless pit. So out of the bottomless
pit comes a power that is to take over
the whole earth and at the same time
something else arises that is to
counteract that power. Let's see.
Revelation chapter 10. And I saw another
mighty angel come down from heaven
clothed with a cloud,
and a rainbow was upon his head, and his
face were as it were the sun. Ezekiel
had a similar vision. Daniel had a
similar vision. This is a prophecy that
deals with something important because
Christ himself is going to tell us what
it's all about. So let us study
Revelation chapter 10 and see where it
brings us
in Revelation chapter 10. As we have
seen this mighty angel with a rainbow
upon his head, the face like the sun,
his feet as pillars of fire,
and he had in his hand a little book
open.
That's fascinating.
And I heard a voice from heaven saying
unto me, Seal up those things which the
seven thunders uttered, and write them
not.
Seven thunders, the voice of God if you
like over all seasons. And he had in his
hand a book and a sealed.
Interesting. Where in the Bible do we
read about a sealed scroll?
Daniel.
In fact, Daniel's 2,300 evening morning
prophecy is the only prophecy in the
whole of the Bible that's sealed. And
it's sealed unto when?
The time of the end. Now, as we were
studying the book of Revelation, every
time we come to this sixth period, then
we go into the time period after 1798.
Isn't that interesting? That's exactly
the right time period. and the French
Revolution, Revelation chapter 11, the
power that comes from the bottomless pit
that makes war against God's word and
against God's truth. All of these issues
happen around that date. Here's a
counter. God says, "Here's a scroll in
my hand. Seal up the things which the
seven thunders uttered and write them
not." And the angel which I saw stand
upon the sea and the earth, lifted up
his hand to heaven to swear by him that
liveth forever and ever, who created
heaven, and the things therein in are,
and the earth, and the things that
therein are, and the sea, and the things
which therein are. What is that? That's
the seal of God. That's the seal of God.
He created heavens, the things that they
are in, the earth, the things that are
therein, the sea, the things that are
therein. And where do we find that
portion of scripture? In the Old
Testament? In which commandment?
>> In the fourth commandment, which gives
validity to the whole law because the
seal of his authority. I make this law
because I am the creator of heaven and
earth, the sea and all that in them.
So the seal of God appears here and
there should be time no longer. What
time? Either it's the end of time as
some interpret it or it means no more
prophetic
time. What was the longest time prophecy
in the Bible? The 2,300 evening morning
ones. And this time period was now
coming to an end. And here was a book
and it was open. Obviously, it had been
closed and sealed. What is going to
happen to the scroll now? The 2,300
evening morning ones is the only one
that was sealed. What's going to happen
to it? Well, he says to the prophet, "Go
and take the little book which is now
open, which is open in the hand of the
angel. Take it and eat it up."
Okay?
What does that mean? Internalize it. Put
it inside you. And it shall make thy
belly bitter, but it shall be in thy
mouth as sweet as honey. Question. What
comes first when you eat something? The
mouth or the stomach?
The mouth comes first and then comes the
stomach. So when he is internalizing the
scroll which is the word of God
sweet
and then
all right and I took the little book out
of the angel's hand and ate it up and it
was in my mouth as sweet as honey just
as he had said and as soon as I had
eaten it digested it as it were
internalized it my belly was bitter.
And he said unto me, "Thou must prophesy
again
before many peoples and nations and
tongues and kings." Whoa, that's
interesting. So, this new commission
over here is a worldwide commission.
Many peoples and nations and tongues and
kings. A worldwide commission. Now, why
prophesy
again?
Is it possible that once you have eaten
this book, once you have internalized
the prophecy that you might think, "Wow,
this is sweet news. Something's going to
happen that will end all trouble here on
earth."
And then it doesn't happen and you find
you have to drudge on. You have to do it
again.
That's interesting. And then still to
many peoples and nations and tongues and
kings.
Well, let's have a look here. Jeremiah
15:16, "Thy words were found, and I did
eat them. And thy word was unto me the
joy and rejoicing of mine heart, for I
am called by thy name, oh Lord God of
hosts." So eating the word of God can
bring joy.
Ezekiel 3:3 and 4. And he said unto me,
"Son of man, cause thy belly to eat and
fill thy bowels with this roll." This is
not a bread roll, by the way. This is a
scroll, a book that I give thee. Then
did I eat it, and it was in my mouth as
honey for sweetness. And he said unto
me, "Son of man, go get thee into the
house of Israel, and speak with my words
unto them." Does everybody understand
now what it means to eat the word of
God? Means to internalize it, understand
it, and then go and preach it.
Now, Ezekiel got the commission to
preach to Israel alone. This previous
commission was to preach to whom?
all the nations, the peoples, the
languages, and the tongues. That was the
previous commission. So, here was an
internal commission. A scroll was to be
understood and it was to be preached.
Okay? Now, remember in 1844,
around about that date, Miller had
preached. It seems to me that the 2,300
day prophecy, exactly the right time, he
starts studying a book that had been
sealed. And now this book is open and
the world Christians come together and
they study this. Remember that over 200
ministers alone from different
denominations studied these prophecies
and they decided wow maybe it means
Jesus is coming again.
That's a sweet message. Maybe we don't
ever have to worry about anything. They
prepared themselves for the coming of
the Lord. It didn't come
and it turned to
bitterness in their stomach and many of
them disappeared. Only a core remained
and said something's wrong. We
misunderstood something. We missed
something. There must have been a finger
over this part of the prophecy that we
didn't understand.
Now, is this fair of God or is this
unfair of God? Well, did he perhaps deal
like this in the past as well? for a
particular reason. And the answer is
yes.
Revelation 10:11, thou must prophesy
again before many peoples and nations
and tongues and kings. Do you remember
when the Jews had crucified Jesus? What
was the state of the apostles and the
followers of Christ?
They were dejected, destroyed. Why?
because they had believed Jesus would
never be crucified. He will announce
himself as the Messiah and the kingdom
would come. That's a sweet message. And
it turned to
bitterness and grief. And here are two
men walking on their way to Emos, their
feet dragging along. They were so
dejected, so miserable. Why? because
their sweet expectation had turned to
bitterness. And then a third one came in
amongst them and said to them, "Let me
explain to you the scriptures." And
starting from where?
From the beginning, he explained to them
all the prophecies concerning himself.
Isn't that wonderful? And what happened
after they suddenly clicked? What
happened?
Wow. There he was. He came into their
home. He broke bread and they recognized
him. And they took off like greased
lightning and ran all the way back to
Jerusalem. Away was the lethargy. There
was spring in the step. And they raced
back with a tremendous message. Isn't
that correct?
And suddenly the scriptures were open to
them and they understood the prophecies
concerning Jesus Christ and the truth
crystallized in their hearts and they
went off with power. That's what
happened then. Why was this great
tribulation if you like this great
bitterness permitted?
Well, there were many many hangers on
that were following Christ for the sake
of what? getting into this new kingdom.
That's it. But to give up self, no way.
To be ridiculed, no way. Not even Peter
could stand the ridicule. The ridicule
of a woman that said, "You're one of
them, too." Nah, not me. Remember that?
He couldn't stand the ridicule. So, what
was left was a call that had said,
"Surely we were not deceived. Surely
this was the son of God." Somehow we
have missed something somewhere and only
those that were really sincere remained.
Now when we did the seven churches
we came to just before laudia there was
a Philadelphia group and it said you
were small in number. Do you remember
that? Small in number and they were full
of love and they were without rebuke.
That's the little remnant that remained
there that had been cleansed through
this great disappointment.
And so 1844, unto 2,300 days, then shall
the sanctuary be cleansed. Wow. They
discovered something. The tremendous
sanctuary message, which is the greatest
message of all time, the gospel in the
Old Testament, explaining the ministry
of Christ from A to Zed. He is the door.
He is the sacrifice. He's the one that
washes you the labor. He's the one
that's the light of the world, the
manora. He's the bread of the presence.
He is the incense. He is the high
priest. We have such a high priest. All
these wonderful things suddenly gel.
Wow.
Now, if that earthly sanctuary was
cleansed, then the heavenly must be
cleansed. That means 1844 doesn't mean
Christ is coming. That means we're
living in the time of judgment.
People must make a decision. There must
go a message of judgment and repentance
to the world, to every nation, tribe,
and tongue. You see, the sanctuary is a
mini presentation of the plan of
salvation. A beautiful message, and it
takes a whole lecture to explain that.
What must be prophesied again? What is
it? What is the message that must go to
the world in this time of conflict when
Satan is setting up his kingdom? Well,
you just read a little bit on because it
explains the controversy as it grows.
Revelation 11, this dark kingdom is
being set up. Revelation 12, the clash
between the giants, Christ and his
people, Satan and his people. The next
chapter, chapter 13, the details, the
nuts and bolts of the final attack, the
beast out of the sea, the old system of
church and state working together, the
beast out of the earth, the new system
of church and state working together
against God's people, the implementation
of the mark of the beast, all of these
great issues. What must be preached to
counter that? And I saw another angel
fly in the midst of heaven, having the
everlasting gospel to preach unto them
that dwell on the earth and to every
nation and kindred and tongue and
people. There's the message that must go
out again. Firstly, it's an everlasting
gospel, not a half gospel. A half gospel
says you are saved by your obedience.
That's what the Jews taught.
Modern Christianity, you are saved by
Jesus. stands on one leg and you don't
have to do anything. You don't have to
be obedience. The law's been done away
with. Do whatever you please. Is the
whole of the law. As long as you say, "I
love Jesus." You're okay. But the
everlasting gospel required obedience as
well as recognizing that without Christ
we are nothing. Everlasting gospel. So
it has both components. saved by the
blood of the lamb and as a consequence
if you love him keep the commandments.
That makes sense. Fear God, give glory
to him for the hour of his judgment has
come. There we go. Yonipur. Worship him
that made the heavens, the earth, the
sea, and the fountains of water. So at
the same time,
a message goes out into the world.
Worship the God of evolution. You come
from the slime pit.
same time another message no worship him
who made the heavens the earth and the
fountains of water so the three angels
messages go into the world the hour of
judgment has come Babylon has fallen and
do not accept the mark of the beast and
we've dealt with these issues that's
what's has to be preached to the entire
world so this organization has to be a
worldwide movement it cannot be a local
organization
Matthew 24:14 also says this. And this
gospel of the kingdom,
not the kingdom of this earth that is
being set up by the United Nations and
by Rome. No, no, no. The kingdom of God
shall be preached in all the world for a
witness unto all nations and then shall
the end come. It has to be a universal
message otherwise it doesn't work. And
Jesus ca came and spake unto them,
saying, "All power is given unto me in
heaven and earth. Go ye therefore and
teach all nations, baptizing them in the
name of the Father and of the Son and of
the Holy Ghost. All power is in Christ,
not in some earthly representative of
Christ. Thou art worthy, O Lord, to
receive glory and honor and power, for
thou has created all things, and for thy
pleasure they are and were created."
Revelation 4:11. Not the slime pit of
evolution. Jesus Christ gets the honor
of being the creator of this universe.
Here is the patience of the saints. It's
going to be a battle. Here are they that
keep the commandments of God and the
faith of Jesus. If you keep the Sabbath,
what are you saying to the world?
I believe that God created the world in
six days. For in six days the Lord made
the heavens, the earth, the sea, and all
that in them is. Therefore the Lord God
commanded you to keep holy the Sabbath
day.
See, there you go. I just have to keep
the Sabbath and I am in the throat of
world philosophy. In the throat.
Thou, oh Daniel, shut up the words and
seal the book, even to the time of the
end. Many shall run to and fro trying to
understand the prophecies, but knowledge
shall be increased. It will be
understood at the end of time. This gift
will once again come to a four. So in
the same time period as God raises up
this countermovement to face the world,
you have freemasonry coming in the
world, demoting Jesus Christ. You have
spiritualism teaching there is no death,
life continues forever. You have
theosophy which teaches that Lucifer is
the true son of God. You have all kinds
of false prophets. We've dealt with
them. You have the Joseph Smiths. You
have the Blavatzkis. You have the Alice
A Bailey's and they write hordes of
books which are the literature of the
great institutions of this world. The
United Nations acknowledges this
literature as the fountain of its
resources. The Mormon movement, the
Jehovah's Witnesses, all of these
movements. In the Mormon movement, the
priesthood is taken away from Christ and
given to man. The order of Malchisedc.
Jehovah's Witnesses demote Jesus Christ.
Christian Science movement says we are
God and we are eternal. All these
movements arise at the same time. And
here's this other little movement that
must counteract it. And God's message is
a message of separation. Revelation
18:4, "Come out of her, my people, that
you be not partakers of her sins, and
that you receive not of her plagues.
Wherefore come out of among them, and be
ye separate, says the Lord, and touch
not the unclean thing, and I will
receive you." 2 Corinthians 6:17. What
is the message of the worldly kingdom?
inclusiveness come together. Those who
adopt separateness will sooner or later
stand exposed.
That's what Alice Bailey says. And what
did Robert Miller say, the former under
secretary general of the United Nations?
If you do not join in, if you have a
spirit of separateness, sooner or later
you'll come to regret it. Didn't he say
that? So, we have a clash of ideals.
What does it mean to be ecommenical? The
word ecommenical is derived from the
Greek term ocommen which may be
translated as the whole inhabited world.
It is in seeing this world as gods that
we see ourselves as one. It is in seeing
all the world's people as made in the
image of God that we are called to
protect the welfare of everyone. So here
is a problem
come together separateness.
Priest J O Connell. The final object of
echcommenism as Catholics conceive it is
the unity in the faith, worship and the
acknowledgement of the supreme spiritual
authority of the bishop of Rome. And the
other movement says
do not accept the mark of the beast.
Babylon is fallen. Babylon is fallen.
Separate yourselves. Separate
yourselves. Wow. Here's a recipe for
disaster. And the Bible warns us all the
world wondered after the beast. They're
not going to listen to this message. So
only individuals will listen. Behold, he
comes with the clouds. Every eye shall
see him. Revelation 1:7. A powerful
message. Warn the people. Warn the
people. Christ is coming again. Oh,
Christ is not coming again. We're going
to have peace and safety on this planet
is the other message. We're going to set
up a kingdom here and Rome will rule and
everything will be nice as it was in the
Middle Ages, dark and miserable.
Well, let's have a look at these
attributes again.
It keeps the commandments of God. Is
that biblical?
It has the testimony, which is the
spirit of prophecy, which we haven't
defined in its fullness yet, but we
accept that that's what it must have
because the Bible says so. And the faith
of Jesus.
Well, you'll have to have faith that
Jesus is coming again. And you must have
faith that he will save you just like he
said his father will be there and never
leave him nor forsake him. It arose out
of a great disappointment. There was a
bitterness, a sweetness and a
bitterness.
It preaches three angels messages.
Has to do that on a worldwide basis.
And it therefore has to be a worldwide
movement. Look at those points and tell
me if you know of a denomination that
does that. Is there a denomination that
does that?
Anyone? Do the Baptists do it?
Do the Methodists do it? Do the
congregationalists do it? Do the
charismatics do it? Who does it?
Is anyone out there who does it?
Well, there's one. There's one
denomination and one alone and it is a
worldwide movement. In fact, there are
only two worldwide
denominations that call themselves
Christian. Can you guess which ones they
are? We'll talk about that. This is
Germany. There's a young man with a
radio satellite. The biggest satellite
evangelism in the world today is run by
the church that you're sitting in today.
The biggest satellite evangelism in the
world. This is Germany. Institutes in
Germany. Hospitals.
This is also in Germany. This is in
Rome. Right in the center of Rome. Huge
institutions.
Other hospitals over there. This is
Switzerland. This is England. One of the
colleges in England. This is a camp
meeting held in England. I was a speaker
at this camp meeting. There were a few
thousand people there. A tremendous
health ministry. St. Helena Hospital,
Adventist Hospital, Lominda Hospital.
This whole town is basically Adventist.
Uh, a health ministry in this in this
pharmacy. There are no drugs, only
alternative medicine, health medicine.
This is a little health institute up in
the mountains in Norway with a little
gym with a little health message. They
bake bread which is not full of
chemicals and they supply the whole of
Norway. The whole of Norway is supplied
by this bakery with an alternative bread
without any strange dodium acetates or
whatever noxious compounds there are in
it. A press, a school, a farm, organic
farming, health farming, getting people
back to a healthy lifestyle. Christ
always dealt with the physical needs as
well as the spiritual needs. And so his
people should also take care of the
physical needs as well as the spiritual
needs. How do you reorganize the soil so
that life will come back into the
plants? Did you know that the Adventist
church is a leader in this field
worldwide? It has a whole organization
called ADRA which sets up organizations
that teach people to farm that brings
relief and all those types of things so
that people can sustain themselves and
be healthy. They are in Korea. They are
in the darkest parts of Africa. You can
go and worship under some trees with
them. This is one in Zimbabwe. This is
one in Malawi. This is a hospital. If
you are in Germany and you are a
tourist, you will receive a list of
hospitals. If you go to Africa, for
example, and on that list there will be
all the Adventist hospitals. Every
tourist in Germany receives a can
receive a list like this from their
tourist agency because they'll say those
are the only hospitals where you can be
pretty sure that you'll be safe because
they are hygienic and they'll take care
of you. And uh I'll tell you the
hospitals in Africa, my son's a medical
doctor. Some of them are absolutely
horrendous. You cannot believe the state
that they are in. But when you go to the
Adventist ones, they're clean. They're
nice. Here's a dental faculty. Here's
another one of the hospitals. There's a
theological school. Here's a nice
family.
I love this family. They are so cute.
Look how rich they are. Can you see how
modern their clothes are and how nice
they are? These are really poor people.
And that's a little house where they
live. And that's the man over there. And
his wife is null and his wife. What a
dedicated man. He goes forth. He has no
money. He travels all over the world
with nothing. And he preaches a message
with such power. I stayed with them. I
slept on the floor. They didn't have
beds, so we slept on the floor. What a
wonderful people they are. Really
brothers and sisters. I'm really proud
of them. Here I was in Africa preaching
in this church. I'll tell you, it's a
different thing to preach in Africa.
It's an amazing thing. This service was
to start at 11:00.
No, and this service was to start at
9:00. There was to be a lecture at 9:00.
By 11:00, we only arrived at the church.
That was a nightmare for me. There was
not a soul in the church. And I said,
"We missed it. We were supposed to be
here at 9:00." He said, "No, they're not
there yet."
They started rocking up at about 12. In
Africa, things start when everybody's
there. That's logical.
Why worry about time?
You see, relationships are very often
more important to them than time. For
example, while I was traveling with this
chap, he suddenly saw an old lady
alongside the road carrying a bag. So,
he pulled the car over. You should have
seen this car. This car that even drove
was a miracle. I think it actually drove
sideways all the way. But nevertheless,
he stops this car. He gets up and he
talks to this little lady.
And then he takes her bag and he walks
with her for half a mile. Takes her
upstairs, puts the bag down wherever he
is, comes back almost an hour later. By
this time I'm sweating.
We're now an hour late for church
already. He doesn't say a word. This is
now this null chap. Off we drive and
suddenly he sees someone else. He stops
the car and I think what's this man
doing? Is he totally nuts? gets out of
the car, talks to this man for about
half an hour, gets back into the car,
and so we arrive at the church two hours
late and not a soul there. And of
course, I'm totally freaked out. And
they weren't even there yet. And so
eventually he came up to me and he says,
"I saw you were sweating." I said, "Yes,
why?"
He says, "You thought, you know, we
Africans, we're strange, right?" And he
says, "You know what? I can explain to
you what happens because I happen to
think like you because I was abandoned
as a little child and I was raised by
white missionaries. So I have a western
mindset in terms of time and I had to
learn to be like my people again. See,
you see when I saw that little old lady
there when she was standing there, it
would have been rude of me to drive past
her if she saw me. And I went out and I
got to her and I spoke to her. And it
would have been rude in my culture if I
had said, "I see you carrying a big bag
here. Let me help you quickly."
I'm off in a hurry. You don't do that in
my culture. You say, "How are you?" And
then you go through the whole
chronology. How your kids? How's this
one? How's that one? How's that one?
How's the next one? And finally, you get
to the point you need help with that
bag. And then you come down and that's
it. Now you have fulfilled your
commission. And that's more important
than time in their culture. Now in the
German culture, it's exactly the
opposite. When you go there, you get a
minutin plan. You know about a manutin
plan. Here you may do this and your
prayer may be 1 minute 45 and a half
seconds. Thereafter a guillotine comes
and you're dead.
Now that works well for that culture.
Now which one is God's culture? the one
or the other. I tell you what, both both
are his culture. And we have to
understand the different cultures. So
here they were. They just packed the
place out and eventually there was no
standing room and they were all around
the church and there were more outside
than inside. So I missed nothing and
they stayed till the last lecture was
finished. Who cares when that ends?
So very interesting. This is Herberg
College. Beautiful place in Africa.
And uh here is the patience of the
saints. Here are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. For me, this is the only
denomination that does all of these
things. And of course, it is a
denomination that is frowned upon by
many and they say, "Isn't that a sect?
Why is it a sect?"
because it teaches everything that every
denomination teaches
and even includes those things which the
founding fathers included but refuses to
compromise on many of the other issues
that seem compromisable. You cannot
compromise the word of God. Do you think
this is a perfect church? Oh no, this is
not a perfect church. Jesus described
the perfect church, the last one.
Remember what did he say it was like?
He said they were blind, pitiful, poor,
wretched, and naked.
So if you're looking for the perfect
church, don't go to this one. It in fact
has to be blind, pitiful, poor,
and wretched. That's what it's got to be
like. So I didn't join this church
because of the people. In fact, if it
were for the people, I would still be
running.
Why did I join it? Because of the truth
that it teaches. Every single doctrine
that it has is biblical. Are there
people in the church that fight over the
doctrines? Yes. But they are
established. They are there and they are
biblical. And as long as those doctrines
are biblical, that's fine by me.
and other sheep I have which are not of
this fold. Them also must I bring and
they shall hear my voice. And there
shall be one fold and one shepherd. John
10:16. Not 20 folds, not a hundred
folds, not a thousand, not 2,000. One
fold, one shepherd, Jesus Christ. The
world is uniting under one shepherd, the
Pope in Rome.
I have no problem if they want to do
that. But my Bible says there's one
Lord, one king, and that's Jesus Christ.
And I will follow him wherever he goes.
And the Bible also says that louda
is the last thing on this earth
representing God. Then comes the coming
of Christ. These are serious issues.
Does this church live up to the biblical
criteria? Does it arise at the right
time? Does it preach exactly that this
message that must be preached to the
entire world? Yes.
But remember one thing.
The dragon was wroth with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed. Those who keep the commandments of
God and hold to the testimony of Jesus.
If you want to have peace and quietness,
then don't ever come here
because the wroth of the dragon will be
an experience that we have. I once
started a sermon. How's everybody
feeling this morning? Great. Something
wrong with your religion?
Because in this world, you will have
tribulation.
You will have all these problems. But be
of good cheer.
I have overcome the world, says Jesus.
So don't expect a perfect church. Expect
truth. And where there is truth, you
have people that love the truth. And you
will find them. Where there is truth,
there is wroth and there is strife
because the dragon hates truth. So you
will find people that constantly bicker
and argue about every aspect. Don't look
at the people, look at the truth.
And God will be the only one that you
can ultimately rely on 100%.
So if ever you want to learn to trust
and hold on to Jesus Christ, then try
following the truth. It is an amazing
experience. But as the days of Noah
were, so also
shall be the coming of the Son of Man.
For as in the days that were before the
flood, they were eating and drinking and
marrying and giving into marriage. Boy,
is this world eating and drinking, isn't
it? Everything rel their food is their
religion. Marrying and giving into
marriage. They change relationships like
they change shirts. And they can change
churches like they change shirts. Isn't
that right? You choose a church
according to the music.
Hello. Do you choose your wife according
to her blouse?
Until the day that Noah entered the ark
and knew not until the flood came and
took them all away, so shall also the
coming of the son of man be. Matthew
24:37 39. We are heading for some
troubles times and we will be be
surrounded by issues that don't make
this an easy ministry.
And what was the lot of poor old Noah?
Everybody said, "Noah, great job you're
doing there, building an ark for all of
us. Can't wait to get into that boat,
right?"
No, they mocked him. I'm sure he dragged
even some of his kids into that ark
judging by how they acted after the ark
landed. So they mocked him and laughed
at him. Do you think truth is popular in
the world? Yes or no?
So don't expect a popular truth. Don't
expect a popular message.
Go ye therefore and teach all nations,
teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever I have commanded you. Two
worldwide movements. I'll let you guess
again. Which are the only two movements
that are worldwide in the world today?
Do you think it's Islam? No, it's not
yet worldwide.
Which two movements are worldwide?
I'll give you the one. Roman Catholicism
is a worldwide movement in every nation
of this earth. And there's one other
little denomination that has that same
attribute. That's the Seventh Day
Adventist Church. It's the only one.
It's the only one. The Lutheran are big,
but they're only in about 65 countries.
That's it.
All nations. And lo, I am with you
always, even unto the end of the world.
Matthew 28:19 and 20. Well, physical
healing as well as spiritual healing.
Thou shalt be called the repairer of the
breach, the restorer of paths to dwell
in. If thou turn thy away thy foot from
the Sabbath, from doing thy pleasure on
my holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy of the Lord,
honorable. Isaiah 58:12 and 13. The
restorer of the breach, the law, had
been breached. That must be restored.
The Sabbath must be restored.
Two denominations. This is the American
Bible Society and Church Missions. It's
very small. I just put it there for
reference. Those are all the countries
in the world or all the denominations in
the world. These are all the countries
in the world. And you'll see XXXX
only along one of them of the Protestant
ones. And that's the Adventists. Not the
creator of the universe in Genesis 2:13,
but the Catholic Church can claim the
honor of having granted man a pause to
his work every seven days. That's quite
an interesting statement by Rome made in
1969.
Reason and common sense demand the
acceptance of one or the other of these
alternatives. Either Protestantism and
the keeping holy of Saturday
or Catholicity and the keeping of holy
of Sunday. Compromise is impossible.
That's what the Roman Catholic Church
wrote already in the Catholic mirror in
1893.
Which Protestant denomination keeps
Saturday?
There were two, three, four, five, six
and slowly they whittleled down.
Eventually there is one great opponent
to this message. Sunday is therefore to
this day the acknowledged offspring of
the Catholic Church as spouse of the
Holy Ghost without a word of
remmonstrance from the Protestant world
except one denomination.
You may read the Bible from Genesis to
Revelation. You will find not a single
line authorizing the sanctification of
Sunday. The scriptures enforce the
religious observance of Saturday, a day
which we never sanctify. Cardinal given
the faith of our fathers. That's what
Rome says. What does Rome say further?
The Sunday is purely a creation of the
Catholic Church. American quarterly uh
Catholic quarterly Sunday. It is a law
of the Catholic Church alone. The
observance of Sunday by Protestants is
in homage they pay in spite of
themselves to the authority of the
Catholic Church. These are all Catholic
statements. The Protestant says, "How
can I receive the teachings of an
apostate church? How we ask, have you
managed to receive a teachings all your
life in direct opposition to your
recognized teacher, the Bible, on the
Sabbath?" question the Christian
Sabbath. The Catholics are pretty direct
on this issue. Then they say in Catholic
mirror, "Those who follow the Bible as
their guide, the Israelites and the
seventh day Adventists have the
exclusive weight of evidence on their
side. While the biblical Protestant has
not a word in self-defense for the
substitution of Sunday for Saturday,
Rome is mocking the Protestant world."
And then they say the Adventists are the
only body of Christians with the Bible
as their teacher who can find no warrant
in its pages for the change of day from
the 7th to the 1st. Hence their
appellation, 7th Day Adventists. Rome
knows why we're called Seventh Day
Adventists. Shouldn't the world?
The Catholic Church changed the
observance of the Sabbath to Sunday by
right of the divine infallible authority
given to her by our founder Jesus
Christ. The Protestants claiming the
Bible to be the only guide of faith has
no warrant for observing Sunday in this
matter. The 7th Day Adventist is the
only consistent Protestant. That's the
question box. Catholic Universe Bulletin
1942.
Catholic Church says there's one
consistent Protestant left in this
world. And who do they finger? Is it
seventh day Adventist? Now imagine this.
Who stands rebuked? Rome stands rebuked
because they changed the law of God. And
Protestants stand rebuked because they
go along with Rome. So both groups are
going to be angry with whom?
Both groups are going to be angry with
the Seventh Day Adventist Church. Why?
Because the Seventh Day Adventist
Church, the very name rebukes them.
The very name is irritating.
Seventh day, we keep the law of God. We
try stumble and fall by the grace of
God. We stumble along, but we say this
is the truth and we'll try and live up
to it by the grace of God. Not saying
we're perfect. Number two,
Adventists. We wait for the blessed
hope. We're not interested in a worldly
kingdom. So, everybody hates them. And
they call them a sect. Well, they called
Paul's church a sect. What is sectarian?
What is a cult? What is a cult? Cult is
someone that has an extra biblical
teaching. What's the biggest extra
biblical teaching in the world? Roman
Catholicism is the biggest cult in the
whole of this planet.
Seventh Day Adventist Church as its
official doctrine is we have no other
creed save the Bible.
No other creed.
Here is St. Katherine's Catholic Church
Sentinel
May 21, 1995. The cardinal writing. What
does the cardinal write? People who
think that the scriptures should be the
sole authority should logically become
Seventh Day Adventists and keep Saturday
holy. Catholic Church knows what the
truth is, but they tell you we won't
obey it. You better obey us.
Pope launches crusade to save Sunday.
make it clear that Sunday must not be
worked since it must be celebrated as
the day of our Lord. Seventh Day
Adventist Church says, "Sorry, we cannot
go along with you." The Bible says
something else and you know it.
So, no wonder at the 1999 interfaith
meeting where all the religions came
together. They condemned the Christian
fundamentalists who abuse speech and
whose efforts at converting others
incite hatred and violence. This is not
an effort to convert anyone. This is
putting the truth out into the world.
What you do with it is your business.
You have freedom of choice. That's the
greatest gift that God has given you.
This is truth. Have I ever told you to
become anything? No. I'm just telling
you this is what the Bible says. This is
what they say. This is what the Bible
says. This is what they say. Choose.
That's all.
All present were in accord on two key
points. Pope John Paul 2 was endorsed by
consensus as the planet's chief
spiritual guide and overseer.
And the religious fundamentalists who
refuse to go along with the global
economical movement are to be silenced.
They must be denounced as dangerous
extremists full of hate.
I can't do anything about it. If he
wants to do that, Jesus says, "Go into
all the world and preach the truth, not
a halftruth, not lie." The wall of
separation between church and state that
was erected by secular humanists, God
forbid, and other enemies, God forbid
even more, of religious freedom has to
come down. Those opposing our views are
the new fascists. Keith Tunia, Time
magazine, 1995.
So the church wants to persecute. In
vain they worship me, teaching for
doctrines the commandments of men.
Matthew 15:9. If you love me, keep my
commandments. That's the message. plain,
simple, cuts down to the chase. Choose
Jesus Christ or choose the world. That's
your choice. And the spirit and the
bride say, "Come." And let him that
heareth say, "Come." And let him that is
a thirst come. And whosoever
will, let him take the water of life
freely. That's your choice. Freedom of
choice. What a beautiful point. Choose
the world or choose Jesus Christ. Choose
obedience to the world. Choose obedience
to Jesus Christ. That's the choice.
Jesus is coming soon and I believe he's
going to take his children to heaven.
And the Bible says, "Keep the
commandments of God that you may have a
right to enter." Not because the
commandments save you, because they tell
you where your allegiance lies.
That's the bottom line. Choose thee this
day whom you will serve. The choice is
yours. and God help you with it. Amen.
>> [music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey.
Oh,
hey.
hold on.
Oh
yeah. Oh.
Going
home.